les libyens vont pouvoir profiter d'un
calme relatif en cette fin d'année
depuis octobre le fragile cessez-le-feu
trouvé entre les différents belligérants
et en partie respecté en libye le
rapport de forces est équilibré entre
les deux camps rivaux
d'un côté le gouvernement d'union
nationale gn a reconnu par l'onu et
dirigée par fayez al sa rage et de
l'autre les forces du maréchal haftar
qui contrôlent l'est du pays
grâce au soutien militaire turque les
forces du gnr poussé en juin dernier la
vaste offensive lancée par leurs
adversaires en avril 2019
même si l'intensité du conflit a diminué
la situation reste chaotique en libye et
les interventions étrangères nombreuses
la turquie a ainsi assuré qu'elle
répondrait à toute attaque contre ces
forces présentes sur place ou contre
celle du gn à un soutien réaffirmé hier
à l'occasion d'une rencontre entre les
chefs des diplomaties russe et turc
personne n'a le droit de dire que la
turquie est obligé de quitter la libye
les gouvernements peuvent changer mais
nous avons des liens historiques avec la
libye face à la fermeté affichée par
ankara
le maréchal rallye five star appelle lui
à chasser l'occupant turc
l'homme fort de l'est du pays peut aussi
compter sur le soutien de plusieurs pays
arabes notamment les émirats arabes unis
et l'egypte ce face au risque d'un
nouvel embrasement la russie appelle les
belligérants à respecter le cessez le
feu négocié sous l'égide de l'eau et
demi la situation en libye est très
compliqué oui dans le sud il y a eu des
incidents violents les accords de
cessez-le-feu il n'y a pas si longtemps
le voit les bayous mais depuis la
situation s'est globalement stabilisé et
les accords signés cet été ont été dans
l'ensemble respectées
cela doit être encouragé de son côté la
france exhorte le maréchal haftar à
s'abstenir de toute reprise des
hostilités et à rechercher une solution
politique
c'est donc dans ce contexte toujours
incertain que se profilent des élections
nationales en libye selon un accord
entre les différentes parties
ces scrutins doivent avoir lieu en
décembre 2021 démissionnaire en
septembre
fayez al sa rage est finalement revenu
sur sa décision en attendant la
constitution d'un gouvernement de
transition